hello and welcome to video playing shoot
Chandra no name no name but I have two
losses on the record against the sky so
yeah Queens gambit declined and see what
line in place classical efficiently 7b
six em they're probably somewhat under
rated line so decent way for black to
play if you like to gather let's explore
position and the position that is less
likely to be simplified quickly so it's
a good fighting options option further
for the black player we'll see what
happens in this game after taking on
this usually either 95 or some play bass
with c5 mmm this you don't see that
often interesting couple of options I
think I'll I'll try this try to UM let
this bishop on h5 look a little bit
misplaced
okay so am I retreating the bishop now
not sure that I that I want I mean I can
do this my development is really really
good here I mean I'm a huge bishop pair
junkie but with development like that I
don't object much to give up one of my
bishops politics was also interesting
okay i'm here at d5 is the most obvious
move but Bishop t6 might the id-5 is
opening up the position but i'm not sure
sure that i want that at the moment that
could I mean that quickly had this
particular time c5 g5s is very likely
good for Wyatt yeah this is definitely
I'm sorry an alternative tried to be
active here in the center see if I d5
again is probably good for wide-eyed
seemed okay he plays it anyway so let's
go ahead
hmm that's not a rule 5 had considered
unfortunately I don't seem to have any
sacrificial options like taking and f4
looks very loose their Quincy 7 is
probably a good move I don't know I can
go back okay I'll go back
j yeah this is not what I what I wanted
to get but maybe it's still a slight
advantage some some little things I've
been annoying and again six is under tag
and so on okay if I take that there
should be two I don't think so 23 Bishop
t4 is a is blunder so
so okay rook chicks you can take and
make me on the back rank basically and
f4 is a risky move but I probably have
to
otherwise I don't make any headway I'm
still not threatening the porn just yet
but you not happy about coming to the it
the corner with this back right but so I
don't see an alternative is extremely
slow which is so to be honest quite
suspicious I already gotten it's got a
ton of ton of games and some probably
it's an okay account so Queen to h5
I'll take f7 King eggs now okay okay you
cannot take on a four because of Bishop
f7c three is also not possible so I'm
probably just threatening to take on c4
now maybe he goes he goes g6 I can still
take on f cell if i take now see if I've
is hanging but I can take c4 right
nothing wrong with that I thought what a
strange move ok so and four is the tect
i think i'll just go back and cover that
and I'm album like I'm up lots of time
maybe at bishop's is 6m
check now Matt satellite resides very
strange time management but black kids
he spent ages okay we had a fairly
fairly normal kind of opening this is
some that was a surprising decision
let's say my back and I'm just
centralizing here yet well here I've
given up the bishop pair which is not
ideal but at least my development is
excellent is six yeah i was thinking d5
but Bishop d6 did did irritate me other
things I mean like taking the kind of
this is this is very nice actually I saw
this variation I but he's got this one
okay maybe this yeah it is irrelevant
because he has this move and now I have
to go back and this is getting nowhere
okay yeah so probably this movie is okay
yeah you form trying to get something
going this
Neji form yeah and I thought can hear I
should have a very very slight advantage
maybe it's nothing serious this this is
c4 yeah that was a that was a good move
no I couldn't I couldn't take off course
yeah this is the issue and therefore was
the risky decision and it is absolutely
not liked by the engine I'm still a bit
surprised the a this is what he played
and this is played by the engine why is
he five bad RC 2 is good okay immediate
attack okay yeah yeah afternoon where I
cannot go here because his hangs and if
I do this then this one it's okay yeah
so that all the big opportunity for
black push c3m yeah yeah i'm i'm
actually better this g6 um the engine
gives cringey for i was thinking i can't
actually take but this is the move mmm
important and now i'm not everything is
this back begging all the anti anti
gesture overstepped the time limit yeah
he never really accelerated her in this
in this game surprisingly okay well
thanks for watching